Guten Tag. Mein Name ist Glitchasch. Ich bin die Diensthaber der Ärztin auf dieser Station.
Zunächst werde ich Ihnen einige Fragen zu Ihren Personchendaten stellen.
Danach besprechen wir Ihren aktuellen Beschwerden. Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Patrin Müller.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihren Vor- und Nachnamen langsam buchstäbigen?
Mein Name ist K-A-T-R-I-N.
Nachname ist M-I-L-L-E-R.
Mein Name ist Katrin Müller.
Katrin, meine Sie?
Katrin, genau.
Katrin Müller.
Wie alt sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin geboren, 14.08.1979.
Ja.
14 oder 40. Ich konnte nicht gut verstehen.
14.08.1979. Ich bin 46 Jahre alt.
46 Jahre alt. Okay, okay. Dankeschön.
Und wie groß sind Sie, Frau Müller?
Ich bin 1,65 m groß und ich wege ungefähr 70 kg.
70 kg, okay. Wie heißt Ihre Hausärztin oder Ihr Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt heißt Herr Dr. Schmidt.
Herr Dr. Schmidt.
Okay, danke schön. Ja, Frau Müller, wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ich komme heute zu Ihnen, weil ich seit mehreren Tagen, aber auch
Wochen zunehmende Luftnot haben, wenn ich mich belaste.
Ich fühle mich sehr abgeschlagen und ich kriege nichts mehr auf die Reihe.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Ich schaffe nichts mehr.
Ah, okay, okay.
Und jetzt, wie fühlen Sie sich?
Haben Sie starke Atemnot?
Nein, nein, nur wenn ich mich belaste.
Wenn ich mehr gehe oder Treppen aufsteige,
dann habe ich diese Beschwerden.
Okay, seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden?
Ganz genau.
Also, das wird jetzt immer mehr.
Ich habe das schon seit November schon.
Seit November, okay.
Seit zwei Monaten.
Seit zwei Monaten, ja.
Okay, zwei Monaten.
Haben Sie Brustschmerzen auch?
Nein, ich habe aber Herzklopfen, wenn ich mich belaste.
Herzklopfen.
Okay.
Aber nur bei Belastung, oder?
Richtig, genau.
Wie viele Steppe könnten Sie ohne Pause hochsteigen?
Also, ich wohne in der dritten Etage.
Ja.
Und ich schaffe das schon.
Wenn ich oben bin, dann muss ich erst mal tief durchatmen.
Okay.
Und ich habe dann auch Schwindel, wenn ich oben bin.
Haben Sie oder ist Ihnen schwindelig,
wenn Sie bei Treppen hochsteigen?
Genau, wenn ich mich belaste.
Okay, okay.
Haben Sie begleitende Symptome wie Überkeit erbrechen?
Nein, das habe ich nicht.
Okay.
Gibt es in Ihren Beinen Schwellungen oder Schmerzen, Frau Müller?
Nein, das ist mir nicht aufgefallen.
Okay.
Haben Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher gelebt?
Das ist das erste Mal.
Erst mal.
Okay, erst mal nicht.
Und haben Sie keine Schmerzen?
Nein, ich habe keine Schmerzen.
Okay, nur Atemnot.
Und ja, haben Sie irgendwelche Herzerkrankungen?
Nein.
Frau Müller, wie ernähren Sie sich im Alltag?
Also, er ernähre mich eigentlich normal.
Ich esse jetzt nicht so viel Fleisch, aber ich würde es normal sagen.
Zum Beispiel viel Fettsiges Essen?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Ich versuche mich gesund zu ernähren.
Okay, sehr gut.
Machen Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich bin früher, bin ich auch viel gelaufen,
aber in den letzten sechs Monaten deutlich weniger,
weil ich halt immer diese Müdung habe, diese Schwäche habe.
Seit sechs Monaten?
Ja, aber seit zwei Monaten ist das extrem.
Extrem.
Also seit zwei Monaten merke ich das mehr.
Okay, aber normalerweise seit sechs Monaten haben Sie diese Beschwerden,
Atemnot?
Also, seit sechs Monaten mache ich keinen Sport mehr.
Das meine ich.
Wegen dieser, okay.
Ja, weil ich auch keinen Lust mehr habe, aber ich bin ja nicht mehr so belastbar wie früher.
Okay, haben Sie Stress im letzten Zeit, im letzten Monat?
Ja, viel Stress.
Okay.
Viel zu tun auf der Arbeit.
Bitte?
Wir haben auf der Arbeit viel zu tun.
Okay, was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich arbeite im Büro, als Steuerfach angestellte.
Im Büro als Steuerfach angestellte.
Okay, Fach eingestellte.
Was machen Sie ganz genau?
Ich arbeite im Steuerbüro.
Ja, okay.
Und in letzter Zeit gibt es viel Stress, als früher.
Ja, wir haben viel zu tun, unglaublich.
Okay.
Okay, und ja.
Haben Sie, före Sie sich in letzter Zeit niedergeschlagen, hoffnungslos, baurig?
Ja, habe ich Ihnen gesagt, sehr abgeschlagen.
Okay.
Sehr abgeschlagen.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit weniger Lust haben,
haben Sie, Schuldewong, deutlich weniger Lust und Freude
an Dingen, die Sie sonst gerne tun?
Nein, ich würde gerne, aber ich schaffe es irgendwie nicht.
Okay, okay.
Ich würde gerne, aber ich schaffe es nicht.
Okay.
Ich würde am liebsten den ganzen Tag schlafen.
Okay, ganzen Tag schlafen.
Hat es Ihr Gewicht oder Appetit in letzter Zeit verlandert, Frau Müller?
Nein, nicht.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihr schlafen?
Gut, sehr gut.
Sehr gut.
Okay.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Masse lassen oder Stuhlgang?
Nein.
Nein, prima.
Und haben Sie Fieber nach Schweißstelfrost?
Nein.
Sie haben Leiden unter Herzklopfen und bei Bewegung.
Und haben Sie Atemot?
Aber leiden Sie keinen Herzrasen oder Herzstolpern?
Hab ich richtig verstanden?
Nein, Herzklopfen.
Herzklopfen.
Ich belast habe ich sehr, sehr starkes Herzklopfen.
Okay, okay.
Und bei Bewegung fühlen Sie enge Gefühle oder Brustschmerzen?
Keine, oder?
Nein.
Brauchen Sie in der Nacht viel Kissen wegen dieser Atemnot?
Leiden Sie unter Husten?
Nein.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Periode, Frau Müller?
Normaler.
Ich würde noch als normal werden.
Okay.
Was meinen Sie damit?
Es dauert ungefähr 10 Tagen oder?
Ja, ein bisschen stärker als sonst.
Stärker, okay.
Besuchen Sie Ihre Frau Erzten regermisig?
Ich war zuletzt vor 2 Jahren da.
Ah, okay.
Wegen dieser Beschwerden, vermerz' ich stärker Blutungen.
Haben Sie schon besucht, Ihre Frau?
Nein.
Nein, okay.
Vielleicht Sie sollten Ihre Frau Erzten besuchen, Frau Müller.
Das wäre gut.
Okay.
Nun hätte ich einige Fragen zur Genus-Smitzellen, Frau Müller.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche nicht, nein.
Okay, haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, ich habe noch nie mehr.
Okay, prima.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Ganz, ganz selten.
Vielleicht einmal oder zweimal im Jahr.
Okay.
Ein, zweimal im Jahr.
Und was trinken Sie?
Kommt drauf an, also Wein oder Cocktail.
Okay, alles kann sein.
Verstehe.
Und nehmen Sie sich bitte diese Frage nicht persönlich.
Ich muss diese Frage jedem Patienten stellen.
Nehmen Sie Drogen?
Nein, ich nehme keine Drogen.
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Allergie oder Unverzweglichkeiten?
Gegen Hausstor.
Wie äußert sich diese Allergie?
Niesen, Juckreiz, Haugen trellen.
Ja, ja.
Juckreiz.
Gibt es oder leiden Sie an einer chronischen Erkrankung?
Nein.
Stärken nicht.
Haben Sie auch nicht bekannt?
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon einmal operiert?
Ich habe eine Kindheit, habe ich die Mandeln entfernt bekommen.
Okay.
War diese Operation komplikationslos?
Ich denke schon, ist schon lange her.
Okay.
Nehmen Sie regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente ein?
Selten.
Selten, welche Medikamente?
Wenn ich mal Kopfschmerzen habe, wenn ich jetzt viele Stress habe, dann nehme ich mal eine Ibuprofen ein.
Frau Müller, gibt es in Ihrer Familie chronische Erkrankungen?
Meine Eltern haben beide Bluthochdruck.
Okay.
Und mein Vater hat eine Prostataphergrößerung.
Haben Sie Geschwester?
Ich habe eine ältere Schwester.
Die ist aber gesund.
Okay.
Sie arbeiten im Büro als Steuerfach in...
Entschuldigung?
Angestellte.
Ja, Steuerfach eingestellter.
Leben Sie allein oder haben Sie Familie?
Ich lebe mit meiner Katze zusammen.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Nein.
Okay.
Frau Müller, sind Sie vorständig geimpft?
Ich denke ja.
Und haben Sie in letzter Zeit eine Reise gemacht?
Ich war zuletzt im Sommer, war ich in Spanien.
Letzt im Sommer, okay.
Okay, alles klar.
Ja, Frau Müller, ich möchte wissen, ob Sie in den letzten Monaten oder in der letzten Woche eine Erkältung haben?
Also ich war nicht erkältet, nein.
Nein, okay. Leiden Sie unter kein...
Halsschmerzen?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit Gelenkschmerzen?
Nicht wirklich, aber ein bisschen Kopfschmerzen wegen dem Stress.
Aber gegen Stress.
Seit wann leiden Sie unter Kopfschmerzen?
Ja, das ist jetzt auch seit November ungefähr.
Seit November.
Ja, viel Stress im Büro, viel zu tun.
Müller, war das nicht so?
Also diesen Stress habe ich vorher nicht so stark gehabt, nein.
Okay, ich verstehe.
Haben Sie während Sie Treppenhochsteigen oder bei Belastung,
Zitzen in der Hände oder ist Ihnen aufgefallen, dass Sie in letzter Zeit blästliche Farbe haben?
Mir selber ist das nicht aufgefallen, ich habe auch keinen Zittern.
Ich bin sowieso sehr blass, schon immer gewesen.
Ich war schon immer blass.
Okay.
Wann war Ihre letzte Hausarztkontrolle?
Wann war die?
Das war, ich glaube Anfang des Jahres, da war ich wegen einem gepalten Infekt,
also letztes Jahr, nicht dieses Jahr.
Welche Infekt?
Gepaler Infekt war ich dort.
Gepaler Infekt, okay, okay.
Fast ein Jahr her.
Okay, war diese Untersuchung ganz normal?
Ich habe einen Infekt gehabt, einen Gepaler Infekt.
Okay, okay.
Ja, Frau Müller, ich muss jetzt kurz gucken, ob alles in Ordnung und alles reicht für mich ist.
Ein Moment.
Seit mehr als zwei Monaten haben Sie extrem zunehmende Luftnoten.
Sie haben diese Beschwerden nur bei Belastung.
Außerdem haben Sie starke Abgeschlagenheit.
Bei Belastung haben Sie auch, oder war Ihnen auch, schwindelig.
Sind diese Beschwerden zum ersten Mal aufgetreten?
Sie haben kein Herzerkrankung.
Sie haben keine Schwellung in Ihrer Beine, oder?
Nein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kontakt zu hustenden Personen in Ihrer Umgebung?
Zu was?
Hustenden Personen.
Nein.
Alles klar.
Ich glaube, ich habe alle wichtige Informationen bekommen, Frau Müller.
Möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Nein, ich ...
Ich würde gerne wissen, was ich habe.
Das ist sehr früh, um etwas zu sprechen, Frau Müller.
Jetzt brauche ich einige Untersuchungen.
Zunächst werde ich Ihr Revitalparameter messen,
Blut abnehmen.
Danach werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Danach werde ich Torax Röntgenaufnahme durchführen.
Außerdem werde ich auf jeden Fall ein EKG schreiben.
Wenn wir alle Ergebnisse zusammengetragen haben,
werden wir miteinander noch einmal sprechen.
Super. Vielen Dank.
Legen Sie sich hin, bitte. Ich komme gleich zur Beschwerden.
Danke schön.
Gibt es noch etwas?
Gibt es uns Fragen ergänzungen?
Ich habe zwei Fragen.
Haben Sie Haurausfall?
Nein.
Haben Sie Konzentration zurück?
Ja.
Danke schön.
Gibt es sonst Fragen?
Dann würden wir einmal zum Arztgespräch übergehen.
Okay.
Bitte schön.
Guten Tag, Herr Oberarzt.
Guten Tag.
Ich habe heute eine neue Patentin aufgenommen.
Haben Sie kurz Zeit dafür?
Natürlich.
Es handelt sich um Frau Katrin Müller.
Sie ist 48 Jahre alt.
Sie hat sich heute wegen mehrer, seit zwei Monaten bestehend,
progradiert,
Belastung abhängiger,
düstener bei uns vor.
Außerdem hat sie starke Abgeschlägenheit.
Seit zwei Monaten war ihnen bei Belastung auch schwendlich.
Diese Beschwerden sind zum ersten Mal aufgetreten.
Bei ihr ist keine weitere Herzerkrankung bekannt.
Normalerweise erinnert sie sich gesund.
Nicht so viel fetziges Essen.
Normalerweise macht sie regelmäßig spazieren gehen.
Aber seit sechs Monaten hat sie kein Lust mehr.
Besonders nach dieser Beschwerden möchte sie nicht Sport machen.
Sie möchte viel schlafen.
Sie fühlt sich hoffnungslos bei der Arbeit.
Sie hat seit zwei Monaten viel Stress.
Sie sollte viele verschiedene Aufgaben machen.
Außerdem hat sie auch Konzentrationsschütterung.
Sie hat sich nicht mehr auf die Begegnung geholfen.
Die Begegnung ist unabhängig.
bis auf die Periode vermehrte Stärke Regalblutungen. Ich empfehle ihr,
ihre Hausärztin so schnell wie möglich zu besuchen. Noch eine Sache. Bei Bewegung leidet sie unter
auch Herzklopfen. Nikotieren und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint. Er trinkt sehr selten Alkohol.
Sie trinkt. Ja, sie trinkt 1-2 Mal im Jahr. Wein oder Salz. Egal. Er trinkt. Ganz selten. Sie hat
Hausstauballergie, die sich die Kreis, Niesen und trennende Augen äußert. In der Kindheit wurde
bei ihr eine Tonselektomie durchgeführt. Sie nimmt Medikamente sehr selten ein. Bei Bedarf
Ibuprofen, während oder wegen seiner Stress hat sie manchmal Kopfschmerzen. Bei ihr ist keine
Vorerkrankungen bekannt. Familienanamnistisch sind beide Eltern, Alteriener hypertonie bekannt.
Außer dem sein Vater leidet und an einer Benin Prostata hyperplazie. Sie ist Büro, sie arbeitet
im Büro als Steuerfach eingestellter und sie lebt allein mit ihrer Katze. Die beschwerden
Sprechen für eine Depression Attacke hin. Differenzial diagnostisch kommen Pulmonärembolie.
Ich habe eine Frage vergessen. Ich sollte fragen, ob sie irgendwelche Vergütungmittel einnimmt.
Während der Untersuchung werde ich diese Frage stellen. Pulmonärembolie und Lutnot,
das kann Asthma in Betracht. Um meine Verdachtstdiagnose bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten zunächst
körpärlich untersuchen. Ich werde Blut abnehmen, EKG schreiben, um mögliche cardiologische
Ursachen auszuschließen. Danach werde ich Röntgenaufnahme durchführen und gegebenenfalls werde ich
Computer Tomography mit Kontrastmittel anordnen, um die Pulmonärembolie auszuschließen oder zu bestätigen.
Sollte sich meine Diagnose bestätigen, werde ich die Patienten... Warum sagen Sie denn,
dass es eine Pulmonal-Attarienembolie sein könnte? Aus welchem Grund? Sie hat zunehmende
Luftnot seit zwei Monaten. Belastungsdruck? Genau, Belastungsdruck. Hat sie Blutdruck, Schwankungen,
etc. haben, hat sie auch nicht, dass sie eine TBT sprechen könnten, ob sie alles nicht. Aber manche
Junggebrauch haben Gendefekte, Gerinnungsströlen haben. Aber es gibt eine viele wahrscheinlich
Das ist eine andere Diagnose.
Was ist das?
Anime?
Richtig.
Sie können ja erzählen, dass sie seit sechs Monaten schon Schwerten hat,
aber seit zwei Monaten ist es sehr stark.
Mit dieser belastungsdürfsten Herzklopfen,
Konzentrationsstörungen, Abgeschlagenheit,
Hypermänneröhe hat sie erzählt.
Sie haben auch ganz gut gesehen und gesagt,
Sie sollte sich mal beim Gynäkologen vorstellen.
Sie ist eine junge Frau.
Genau.
Das ist wichtig.
Ihre anderen Diagnosen, die Sie gestellt haben,
kann man als Differenzialdiagnose auf jeden Fall in Betracht ziehen,
wobei Asthma nicht gut passt.
Asthma ist, dann müsste es schon Belastungs Asthma sein.
Aber auch Depression kann es sein,
als Differenzialdiagnose.
Das ist ja nicht,
dass sie, wenn sie drei Schockdärkte gestiegen ist,
eine Luftnot hat oder Herzklopfen hat.
Das erklärt es mich.
Ich denke, dass hier vielleicht die Eisenmangel-Anämie
in diesem Fall wahrscheinlich sein könnte.
Sie haben total recht.
Was machen Sie denn mit der Patientin jetzt?
Ich konnte bei dieser Patientin ein CT machen,
eine Computertomographie machen.
Nein.
Was machen Sie?
Ihr machen etwas, sagen Sie ruhig.
Für die Anämie sollten wir Blut kontrollieren.
Was würden Sie annehmen?
Ja, in Blut werde ich Hemoglobin,
Hemotokrit,
Ferritinpärte.
Genau, Ferritinpärte kontrollieren, überprüfen.
Und sollte sich,
sollte sich die Anämie bestätigen,
werde ich Ferritin
Medikament verschieben,
verschreiben.
Wieder.
Wie können Sie den Ferritin verschreiben?
Ich habe nicht verstanden.
Es gibt zwei verschiedene Möglichkeiten.
Wir können intravenöse Ferritin verabreichen
oder als Tablette verschreiben.
Wenn die Patientin stark ausgeprägt am Anämie hat,
werde ich intravenös-ferritin verabreichen.
Ferritin oder Ferrum?
Ferrum.
Das ist Eisen.
Dreiwertiges Eisen.
Nicht Ferritin.
Okay.
Machen Sie weitere Diagnostik?
Oder lassen Sie die Patientin danach wieder nach Hause?
Was machen Sie mit dieser Patientin?
Wenn die Diagnose bestätigen und diese
therapeutische Maßnahmen durchführen,
werde ich die Patientin zu Hause...
Ambulanz belassen.
Ambulanz.
Ambulanz behandeln.
Ja, Ambulanz behandeln.
Und ich empfehle der Patientin
sofort Frauenärztin zu besuchen.
Man sollte auch Blutbildkontrollen empfehlen.
Nach sechs Monaten.
Würden Sie weitere Diagnostik empfehlen?
Normalerweise können wir Hemm-Occultest empfehlen
oder durchführen.
Aber in Junggefrau,
diese Alter und sie hat starke Belotungen.
Ich glaube, brauchen wir zum ersten Mal nicht.
Aber wenn sich die Eisenwerte nicht verbessern,
dann sollte man das Ganze nicht nur auf eine Hypermenerol belassen,
sondern man muss weitere Diagnostik machen.
Endoskopische Untersuchungen sind immer ganz wichtig.
Sehr gut.
Wir haben auch andere Patienten,
Zuschauer oder Ergänzungen.
Wichtig ist, dass man nicht jede Anämie stationär aufnehmen muss.
Man muss nicht jede Anämie transfondieren.
Man sagt, wenn man alles, was unter sieben ist,
sollte man Blut transfondieren.
Alles, was über sieben ist,
kann man mit Eisensubstitutionen behandeln.
Man kann auch ambulant belassen.
Aber wenn die Patientin nicht hemodynamisch stabil ist,
also Herzrasen, Schwindel,
unwächtig wird,
dann sollte man sie stationär aufnehmen,
ein, zwei Tage behandeln.
Dann kann man sie wieder nach Hause entlassen.
Aber die Frauenärztin muss die Patientin weitermachen.
Die Patientin wird weiterhin betreuen.
Das ist wichtig.
Aber dauerhaft heftige Schmerzen beschwerden,
oder Herzrasen, zum Beispiel diese Patienten hat Herz gelopft,
aber nur bei Bewegung.
Genau, genau.
Wir wissen noch nicht, welchen Hemoglobin sie hat,
wenn sie jetzt fünf hat oder sechs hat.
Das ist sehr niedrig.
Aber wenn sie acht hat, 8,4 hat, etc.,
dann kann man sagen, ich gebe dir einmal Eisen,
also Infusion, Eiseninfusion,
und dann kann sie wieder nach Hause gehen.
Aber der Hausarzt oder die Frauenärztin
müssen weitermachen, kontrollen machen.
Eigentlich ein ganz einfacher Fall.
Auch Belastungsdispinel,
Belastungsherzklopfen,
meistens Abgeschlagenheit, Konzentrationsstörungen,
Müdigkeit,
meistens eine Eisenmangel-Anemie.
Man muss nicht immer das Schlimmste denken,
wie Bungenembolie,
Herz- und Sehns-Hügel,
oder auch andere Diagnose.
Meistens ist es ganz einfach bei Frauen.
Genau, Sie haben recht.
In der Fälle gibt es keine solche einfacher Diagnose.
Deswegen denke ich, immer Konfizierte.
Ja, genau.
Okay.
Gibt es noch Ergänzung von den anderen Kollegen?
Gibt es Fragen?